Hey, what's up?
It's-
It's me... yah boi
Markiplier, and I
Ohhh~nooo
~high tune for Bob~
[Bob laughing]
It's me, ya boi Markiplier here with the first day of the tour.
And the very first Markiplier shitty daily vlog.
*tck* 'sup?
Bob: Wave it around for once
Wade: It's ya boi, skinny penis
Wade: You've never seen that?
Mark: *laughing* Nooo.
Wade: Oh 'kay... I just- I just thought it up
Mark: Alright, cool
~sick riff for Wade~
Mark: We gotta go uh cause we're in Amsterdam right now but we have to make our way to--
We have to make our way to Tilburg-
uh oh.
Amy: Ohhh Mark
Mark: What did I do?
Amy: It's you, your guitar is too close
Mark: To wha- oohh
Amy: You have to give it space!
Evan: and just all your faces were like "whass goin' on"
Evan: What's going on dude?
Mark: This is Evan
~jazz tune for Evan~
Evan, [terrible Dutch accent]: We are in the ze Amsterdam
*Mark sneezes*
Evan: Bless you.
Mark: Thank you.
Evan: How you feeling Mark?
Mark: I already feel something in my throat
Evan: Okay, well that's a great start.
Bob: You're going right in the front line?
Evan: Oh shit... Sorry
Bob: Really?
Mark:  Yeah
Bob: Don't you know how to queue?
Mark: Fuck your shit bruh
Bob: You obnoxious Americans.
Mark: Thank you.
*Laughter*
Evan(??): Right in the front.
Bob: Dude that's some ergonomic vlogging shit that I've never seen *laughing*
Bob: You know that the screen faces you.
Mark: Shut up I don't have 'nother--
Bob: I don't know if you're interested
Mark: I don't have another hand to turn this
Whooaaa look at.. that man!
It's Evaaaannnnn
Kathryn: Evaannnnnn
Mark: Tyler, don't move
*Mark making a strange sounds*
Anyway, I'm gonna be doing daily vlogs on my way
They're gonna be... uhhhh....
..."Very" professional. *laughter*
Ethan: I just loved how awkward th-
Amy: Ohh it's just my eyes
*Mark laughs*
Amy: Hulloh
~magical music for Amy~
Amy: I could get you from a sweeter angle
Mark: What are you talking about? This is-
Amy: I know what I got
Mark: N-no you don't know how sweet this angle already is
Amy: Yeah, you know
Mark: This is a-- aaahh mannn... Now it's not a vlog
Mark: That's a documentary
Amy: Just, just stick your arm out pretend like you're
Mark: Heyyy guys.. hey guys...
Amy: That's not gonna...
*Laughter*
Hey, hey guys. Heyy
Amy: There you go... Super ARM
Mark: Welcome to my uh... super-sweet shitty vlog
Uhhh, we're going to Tilburg.
And uhh... we
*more laughter*
Amy: I think there's just a shadow of your own hand on your face
Mark: This?
Amy: I dunno whose hand was that?
Amy: is that you?
*Tyler laughs*
Tyler: I was just -- casually
~sick riff for Tyler~
Tyler: Wade you wanna gonna do a bus vlog when you're in the... luggage department?
Wade: Why would I be in the luggage compartment
Wade: Toby don't ride in the luggage.
Molly: God
Wade: Tohh-BEE
[Mark zooms Ethan]
Mark: You dunno about Toby?
Ethan: Tobyyy, Tobler, Tobyyy
Wade: Tohbeh in da hawse!
Ethan: Toby..
Ethan: Tobyy
Mark, Wade and Ethan: Tobbyyy
~intense music for Ethan~
Mark: How many people use a camcorder to vlog?... FOOLS!
~calm journey music~
*music fades*
I did a sweet artistic shot.
Amy: It's good
Amy: You were looking out the window?
Mark: Yeah, I was.
Mark: Yeah, it was very good.
Amy: Happy Valentine's day everybody.
Mark: Oh yeah, Happy Valentine's day.
Tyler: Thanks, Mark.
Mark: Not you!
*laughter*
Amy: Happy Valentine's day to everyone but Tyler
Mark: NOT YOU
Bob(??): Thank You
Mark: De Goot, de Groot fresh group
It's Groot
*Laughter*
Wade: That's some good footage you got there, Mark.
Mark: Thanks, man.
Alright, we're almost at Tilburg.
We've already made our first fatal travel mistake.
Nobody brought water, so I assume we're going to die in short order.
*sigh*
We were not prepared for this.
We were not prepared for the rigors of the Netherlands.
Mark: Wade, you're next to be eaten.
That's fine.
I'm hoping one day that stem cell research will advance to the point where we can make burgers of ourselves and eat only us...
So, I'd eat a Wade Burger...
*Mark laughs*
Wade: Tilburg, we're in Tilburg today, right?
Today's Tuesday?
Mark: Tilburg Tuesday!
Ethan: Tilburg Tuesday!
Ethan: Ya ya, prra prra
Amy: It is Wednesday
Kathryn: It is Ash Wednesday.
Mark: Tilburg Wednesday!
Mark: Werktalent? That's me!
Alright fam-fam, we're here.
So this is the place, there it is.
Covered in what seems to be CDs.
Just another classic place we're gonna wreck with our presents.
H-hey, woah!
Dan: Yeah woah, extreme close-up!
Anyway, time to go in and rehearse
The show's slightly different than it was.
We have to have intermissions in Europe, for some reason.
Because our show's just so fucking good that they can't handle ninety minutes of unadulterated us.
Yooooooooooooooooooooooooo, there he is!
~high tune for Phil~
Woah, Phil!
Group: *saying Phil multiple times over*
Phil: You guys are great, I missed you guys a lot.
*Phil laughs*
Mark: Kristen
Bob: Kristen
Kirsten: Hello
~high tune for Kristen~
Group: Chaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaase.
Chase: What up guys!
~high tune for Chase~
Chase: Hi!
Mark: Alright!
Mark: Carla!!!!!
~high tune for Carla~
Carla: Hey.
Bob: Carlaaaa!
Bob: Carlaaa!
I'm just doing all the Mark memes, just getting them out of my system .
Mark: Keto, I did Keto.
*incoherent mumbling*
*Mark laughs*
Bob: Did you lose about fifteen pounds in the first two weeks?
Mark: Yeah man, it's crazy, man.
Bob: yeah, it's crazy.
Mark: Gives you a headache in the first, you know three days, but then you get over that and then it's crazy.
Bacon... Butter... anyways.
Bob: *wheezes* Are you just mumbling?
Mark: Yeah. *laughter*
Bob: Bacon and... a lot of butter *incoherent mumbling*
Amy: Ah!
*Kathryn has been spotted*
Mark: Alright, fuccbois
Mark: *Stomps around being goofy*
Tyler: Ha!
Mark: Check it yo.
Amy: Dude, the stage looks so cool, look up there.
*OOoooooooh*
First, the sweeping panorama.
*Cool sweeping panorama sound*
Mark: Ah, earlybirds.
*Loud hammering in the background*
*Loud hammering gets louder*
Mark: I've been spotted!
Male: Mark! Mark!
Female: Oh mah gaawd!
Mark: A good peep. Hehehe, okay.
Mark: Well well welll.
Mark: PEWWWWWWWWDIEEE-PIIIE-EH!
Wade: That's right it's been me the whole time.
Mark: That's my joke.
Wade: That's my joke!
Mark: That's my joke!
Mark: Just cause you did it all the time doesn't mean that you-
Wade: I've been making that joke since the first tour.
Mark: I- I've been talkin' about that joke since before the tour.
Wade:Yeah yeah, before THIS tour.
Mark: For your tour!
*Ethan laughs maniacally offscreen*
Ethan: Hey.
Amy: Hey!
Mark: Hi!
Let me tell you about the Tilburg ghost.
Amy: Oooovvv!
Mark: There it is!
Amy: Hey.
Alright so we're gonna- what we're gonna do is we're gonna rehearse and then we're gonna do a show.
Mark: Tck.
Tyler: Is- is that the new hurdle?
Phil: Ordering it in Dutch, apparently, is harder than we thought.
*Laughter*
(Tyler is laughing a bit too hard. He lost it XD)
Wade: This is what I'm carrying now?
Tyler: I love this!
Wade: It's fucking s-
*hurdle breaks*
Mark: Track standards are a little lower in the Netherlands...
Mark: Alright what up, it yo boi.
Mark: Now, here's how we gonna do. We're going over up to the stage, and we're 'bout to do us some improv.
Mark: We getting ready fo' the show, the show is not gonna blo' and we ain't gonna show nobody no bad.
Mark: And we gon' go out there and we gon' do good, okay?
Mark: Alriiiiiiiiiight.
Mark: Is that me? Move, move!
Amy: What?
Mark: Move!
Amy:What?
Mark: Outta the way!
Mark: Awwwww, shit!
Mark: *grunts violently while zooming in on grundle*
Alright it is day flippin' one, I already have a sore throat.
Fucking travel will do it to you every single time.
You can't survive against it, just kills you, no matter what
*Loud burp*
Mark: Ooh!
Ethan: Oh, it's a push!
Ethan: Hehe, I didn't- I couldn't figure out how to open it last time cause it's a push not a pull.
Ethan: But now I got it.
*Epic music in the background*
Mark: Alright... So, we're about to start the rehearsal
Wade: *unintelligible*
Mark: *cries and laughs*
Mark: So we're about to start rehearsal and- uh- we g-
Mark: *grunt*
Ethan: I said get ready to cum!
*Laughter*
Got done with the rehearsal, we killed it, smashed it out of the park.
Uh, next up is lunch, and I actually got to practice my songs, I suppose.
Hey! I just got done with my acoustic performance for the V.I.P. set
I didn't record any of it 'cause a little-
H-here's how it went, Amy hold this.
*Mark plays on the guitar*
~ I met you in the dark ~
~ You lit me up ~
~ I fell in love and then I touched your butt ~
~ I've got no idea where I put my keys ~
~ There ain't nothin' better than... ~
Amy: ~ Petting some bees ~
Mark: ~ Petting some bees ~
Alright, I'm gonna go check in with the boiz.
Mark: Yo.
Wade: Yo.
Mark: How you feel about the show tonight?
Mark: Man, this lens is dirty.
Wade: Alright, glad I had that moment.
Mark: Alright, there we go, go for it now.
Mark: What do you think of our chances tonight?
Wade: *Clicks tongue*
Ethan: Or bad chances.
Wade: Come on!
Wade: I just gave my thumbs-up!
Ethan: There's no chance, there's no chance of anything.
Mark: Oh yeah? What has your-
Wade: Stop, stop.
Mark: -dick have to say about that?
Ethan's weiner: There's no chance of anything, Papa Bear.
Mark: Nooooooooooooo!
Wade: Dan's dick has some better things to say.
Mark: Okay, Dan's dick what do you have to say about that?
Dan's dick: Better be in two!
Mark: Shit!
Bob: What are you dicks talking about?
Ethan: What does your dick have to say about the show?
Mark: Yeah, what does your dick have to say?
*Bob flips a birdie for thug life dick*
Mark: Is that you or the penis?
Bob: It's his hand.
*Crowd cheers*
Alright, I'm done.
Go see pictures of Chica.
Go look up pictures of Chica on my Instagram and like my Twitter.
Go look at those, those are real cute.
Okay alright, love you, bye!